I've never met anyone who thinks he was
any good David Cameron I really do live
in an echo chamber because I've never
met you before anyone who thinks that I
[Music]
[Music]
think the safe spaces can be used as as
a kind of escape route when it's just oh
I need I need some time out from this
particular issue and it can be used as a
way to shout down someone else opinion
there's a lot of danger in modern debate
for people just saying I can't bear to
hear what you're saying because it's
offending and triggering me too much but
sometimes you need to hear the things
that that other people find offensive so
sometimes you need to listen to stuff
which you don't agree with and find a
way to argue back to it rather than kind
of hide in some sort of bunker which is
a safe space of hearing an idea you
disagree with is what their being kept
safe from though because when you say
safe the opposite of safe is basically
being in danger yeah and that's and if
people feel like they're in danger if
family we should listen to them I think
people should be allowed to express
opinions that other people violently
disagree with and you should be
encouraged to have proper debates about
it but I mean the definition of safe
space seems to be protected from from
ideas that that may but they may find
offensive and I don't think people
should be protected from ideas that they
find offensive
[Music]
I didn't even think this was a
controversial point I thought they had
what you go on explain I was just
reading that 130,000 disabled people
have died because of austerity I don't I
I did not tell me your because I didn't
even think this was I thought this was a
fact in a way I completely mean and I
think hollowing out public services can
be an absolute nightmare
I think it's quite hard to say that
definitely a lack of money was the
problem behind X Y Zed whatever
sometimes it's colleagues broken systems
and that sometimes there's just you've
got to cut money out and find another
way to solve the problems just there was
a lot of money for brexit after Theresa
May said there was no magical money tree
for things like mental health services
homelessness services and I mean when
they launched an inquiry into whether
and why the homelessness problem had
gotten so bad I thought this is
astonishing and I feel like they would
be able to see it with the naked eye if
these people ever walked anywhere
think it's dangerous to sort of bandy
around the word transphobic too readily
there's a sort of level of skeptics not
natus cats and not sort of sitter just
kind of let's analyze this huge
phenomenon sensibly
and see you've got to be allowed to ask
questions when something this big is
happening with literally any prejudice
you always get this we got this with
Islamophobia you get it with you even
get it with sort of fat phobia people
framing their arguments as concern when
there's something a little bit nastier
underneath I actually think it's
dangerous to sort of dismiss the people
who are saying actually your concerns
are hurting me and so perhaps what's
what's needed right now is much kind of
language brexit now you go okay breaks
it I honestly don't see what an earth
you could have done in those
circumstances I like I don't think that
that was his best move I'm just
defending but I mean obviously when you
look at it now and the mess that we're
in now whatever side you thought in the
referendum on brexit whatever you
believe on it it does seem to be a mess
I have never met anyone who thinks he
was any good I this I really do live in
an echo chamber because I've never met
you before
anyone who thinks that
I mean she was absolutely lousy
obviously I just feel mean saying
strongly disagree I feel a bit me tried
so hard she was given a difficult hand
she played it very very badly i I don't
know what else to say
yes she got a mess it was horrible
he doesn't do anything he's supposed to
be the hope right now that's the main
reason I'm furious with him is that it
is it's so embarrassing what's going on
and he's supposed to be the hope he's
Petty and sort of vindictive and
everything he says it's so sort of small
and so kind of trying to seek offense
he's just not the person to unite the
country
I'm normally vote conservative but if
there was a good labor leader a strong
labor leader who had ideas and had a way
to unite the country and treated people
with respect then I would probably vote
for that person I was recently in the
last few years told by my mother that
I'm Jewish so I have this weird
perspective where I actually identify
with this group and so I do hear the
anti-semitic dog whistles that happen
but also because I don't present as
Jewish I hear what they say when the
Jews leave the room yeah I just cannot
believe that people like you it just
it's so obviously happening just
wouldn't get these brilliant Labour MPs
feeling like the party doesn't represent
them anymore they're not making it up I
[Music]
don't think particularly that the sort
of higher echelons of the Conservative
Party has a sort of institutional
problem with Islamophobia I think it's
much more of a kind of grassroots
conservative party members issue but I
do agree that it's a problem
that could have been so good
you